[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halbweg guten Abend und
Willkommen an diesem Montag den Sport in
der Sendung präsentiert Norbert Lehmann
der geplante Umbau von Heizungen erhitzt
die Gemüter
heizungsgesetz ja da ist sich die Ampel
einig aber nicht bei der Frage wie es
aussehen und wann es kommen soll
Türkei war Teil 2 vor der Stichwahl
versuchen beide Lager die
Wahlberechtigten in Deutschland maximal
zu mobilisieren
der Traum vom Titel zum Greifen nah der
BVB ist Tabellen erster und könnte am
Samstag zum 9 Mal deutscher Meister
werden
[Musik]
die Unsicherheit über das geplante
heizungsgesetz ist groß doch statt
Klarheit gibt es Krach in der Koalition
SPD und Grüne wollen das Gesetz noch vor
der Sommerpause im Bundestag diskutieren
und verabschieden die FDP stellt sich
quer und verlangt im Kern ein neues
Gesetz das nervt sagt
SPD-Fraktionschef Mütze nicht darum
geht's ab 1 Januar soll möglichst jede
neu eingebaute Heizung mit mindestens 65
Prozent erneuerbarer energiebetrieben
werden wer noch eine Öl oder Gasheizung
hat muss nicht verzweifeln alte Anlagen
dürfen zunächst weiterlaufen und auch
repariert werden wo es jetzt Zoff gibt
zeigt wenn
der Morgen ist noch frisch da platzt dem
ersten der Kragen war immer noch nicht
klar ist was aus dem Gesetzentwurf wird
das bedauere ich und das nervt mich auch
die FDP hat jetzt noch 24 Stunden Zeit
der ersten Lesung des Gesetzes
zuzustimmen und wir haben genügend
Parlamentarierinnen und Parlamentarier
in allen Fraktionen die aus diesem
Gesetz etwas Besseres machen können 24
Stunden sonst kann das Parlament nicht
mehr in dieser Woche mit den notwendigen
Beratungen beginnen daran hängt auch die
Verabschiedung des Gesetzes vor der
Sommerpause und das in Kraft treten zum
ersten Januar nur will dass die FDP auch
gar nicht sie will ein neues Gesetz
sind einfach unfassbar viele Fehler
deswegen sind hier hier brauchen wir ein
neues Gesetz im Prinzip und ähm die
Debatten um punktuelle Veränderungen
sind nicht hilfreich in der Koalition
steht die FDP damit allein der Kanzler
lässt durch sein Regierungssprecher
ausrichten dass er sich Tempo wünscht
rechtzeitig hat er seine Zuversicht
ausgedrückt dass die Kern Bestandteile
des Gebäude der Energiegesetzes auch
verabschiedet werden und einen
Kernbestandteil ist auch eine gewisse
zeitliche Nähe der ist in Kraft treten
soll eine Botschaft an die FDP hat auch
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck erinnert den
Koalitionspartner an Vertragstreue
es ist meine Ansicht nach ein gutes
Gesetz das natürlich immer noch besser
werden kann das imkabinett geeint war
und mit der Zustimmung auch der
fdpressource verabschiedet wurde
und mehr ist dazu eigentlich nicht zu
sagen das wird man morgen sehen ob dann
wieder wem der Kragen platzt oder die
Ampel sich doch noch zusammenrauft die
Zeit läuft
künftig muss sich Philipp nimmermann als
Staatssekretär im Wirtschaftsministerium
mit dem heizungsgesetz auseinandersetzen
er wird Nachfolger von Patrick reichen
der wegen Missachtung von Compliance
Regeln gehen musste nimmermann war
bislang Staatssekretär in Hessen vorher
in Schleswig-Holstein
die hohen Energiepreise als Folge des
russischen Angriffs auf die Ukraine
waren Monate lang das Thema viele sahen
sich plötzlich mit horrenden Gas und
Stromrechnungen konfrontiert die
Regierung reagierte mit der Preis Bremse
jetzt entspannt sich die Lage meldet das
Vergleichsportal Verivox einige
örtliche Grundversorger haben nämlich
die Preise angepasst in den Monaten Mai
Juni und Juli wird Strom im Schnitt um
14% günstiger Gas um 23 Prozent trotz
Ersparnis das Preisniveau bleibt
insgesamt hoch Christoph ist der rell
in Sachen Energie zuletzt fast nur gute
Nachrichten Gasspeicher voll Nachschub
gesichert ein milder Winter ergo rasant
fallende Preise auf den Märkten aber
nicht für die Menschen zu Hause weil
nämlich fast alle Grundversorger ihre
Energie langfristig Einkaufen vor ein
paar Monaten noch extrem teuer diese
Kosten geben Sie in ebenfalls
langfristigen Verträgen an die
Privatkunden weiter doch jetzt also die
ersten Preissenkungen er zaghaft sein
sie findet der kundenschützer das
Verbrauchersicht hält sich das Signal in
Grenzen weil es betrifft nur ungefähr
zehn vielleicht 15 % der
grundversorgungsanbieter im Bereich
Strom und Gas tatsächlich liegen noch
80% aller laufenden Stromtarife so hoch
dass der Staat sie zum Schutz der
Verbraucher Deckel muss was er ab 40
Cent pro Kilowattstunde auch macht beim
Gas muss er fast 90% aller Tarife
Deckeln weil sie über 12 Cent liegen
wirklich sparen aus Kundensicht das geht
derzeit wohl nur per Anbieterwechsel
wenn man darf
wenn Sie jetzt noch in der
Grundversorgung sind ist es sinnvoll
sich auf dem Markt umzugucken die Preise
genau zu vergleichen auch die Qualität
der Angebote zu vergleichen bei Strom
und Gas könnte ein Durchschnittshaushalt
mit einem Neuvertrag rund 1.100 Euro pro
Jahr billiger kommen rechnet das
Vergleichsportal Verivox vor und netter
Nebeneffekt der Staat müsste die dann
auslaufenden teuren Verträge nicht mehr
subventionieren zumal manche Versorger
ihre Preise derzeit sogar anheben aus
dem Bundeskartellamt nicht ganz geheuer
ist
wir haben jetzt erstmal gegen eine
zweistellige Zahl an Unternehmen an
Gasversorgern ein Verfahren eingeleitet
und überprüfen ob diese Unternehmen
möglicherweise die Preise zu Unrecht
erhöht haben
Bewegung ist auf jeden Fall drin im
Markt Richtung Sommer dürfte die Energie
zu Hause für die meisten billiger werden
auch bei langfristigen Verträgen
russische Einflussnahme über ganz
verschiedene Kanäle die beobachten
Deutschlands verfassungsschütze
zunehmend und warnen vor einer
Gefährdung der Demokratie der Präsident
des Bundesamts für Verfassungsschutz
halten wann wirft dabei auch Teilen der
AFD vor russische narrative gezielt
weiterzugeben und weiter zu steuern das
trage dazu bei dass sich
Rechtsextremismus in Deutschland
ausbreiten können
in der Ukraine hat Russland seine
Luftangriffe fortgesetzt in der Region
rund um die Großstadt niepo wurden nach
ukrainischen Angaben mindestens acht
Menschen verletzt die Angriffe in der
Nacht hätten militär- und
Infrastruktureinrichtungen gegolten auch
Wohnhäuser seien zerstört oder
beschädigt worden die ukrainische
Flugabwehr habe zahlreiche Drohnen und
vier Marschflugkörper abgefangen hieß es
wie stark ist die russische Armee in
heute live sprechen wir darüber mit
einem Militärexperten und mit unserem
ukraine-reporter vor Ort um 20 Uhr in
der heute App und auf unseren Social
Media Kanälen der Westen versucht weiter
mit Sanktionen Russland in seinem
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine zu
schwächen am Wochenende waren es die G7
heute trafen sich die Außenminister der
Europäischen Union dabei ging es vor
allem darum dass die Sanktionen auch
greifen und nicht unterlaufen werden
beim Thema Iran hat die EU ein achttes
Sanktionspaket beschlossen die
Strafmaßnahmen richten sich gegen zwei
Einrichtungen und fünf Personen sie
dürfen unter anderem nicht mehr in die
EU einreisen die EU forderte den Iran
erneut auf keine Todesurteile mehr zu
verhängen oder zu vollstrecken
sechs Tage noch dann entscheidet sich in
der Stichwahl ob Präsident Erdogan
weiter die Türkei regiert oder doch sein
Herausforderer kelitzschterolo wichtig
dabei sind auch wieder die hier lebenden
Türken und Türkinnen die schon jetzt
ihre Stimme abgeben können
bei der ersten Runde der Wahl am 14 mai
stimmten sie mit über 65 Prozent für
Amtsinhaber Erdogan
wahlberechtigt sind in Deutschland rund
1,5 Millionen Türkinnen und Türken sie
können rund 2% der Gesamtstimmen in der
Türkei ausmachen
Voraussetzung sie müssen einen
türkischen Pass haben und sich schon für
die erste Wahlrunde registriert haben
eine nachträgliche Registrierung im
Wählerverzeichnis für diese Stichwahl
ist nicht möglich
bis Mittwochabend können die Stimmen
abgegeben werden am 25 Mai werden die
Wahlurnen nach Ankara geflogen und am
Sonntag zur Stichwahl mit ausgezählt
jede Stimme zählt und so versuchen beide
Seiten ihre Anhänger für die Stichwahl
zu mobilisieren zeigt Dominik
der Andrang ist riesig im türkischen
Generalkonsulat in Köln über 100
Kilometer sind manche Deutschtürken
gefahren um hier ihre Stimme abzugeben
die Motivation und die Mobilisierung
sind groß auch bei den erdogan-anhängern
[Musik]
will mit doch auch die die nicht wollen
dass Erdogan länger regiert haben alles
in Bewegung gesetzt eine Tochter habe
ich mitgebracht mein Bruder ist da mein
schwiegerin Freunde von mir sind
gekommen und wir kämpfen eben bis er
geht die meisten Deutsch Türken sind für
Erdogan dessen Unterstützer betreiben
Wahlkampf auf den allerletzten Metern
direkt vorm Wahllokal zwei bekannte pro
Erdogan Influenza Reisen in diesen Tagen
von Konsulat zu Konsulat machen Stimmung
außerdem organisiert Erdogans
akapi-partei kostenlose Shuttlebusse
etwa von Muschi Gemeinden hin zu den
Wahllokalen um ihre konservative
Wählerschaft an die Urnen zu bringen
beobachtet der Journalist
ehrenüberziehen sie konzentrieren sich
auf die Moschee Strukturen weil dort
ihre klassische Wähler Klientel ist und
deswegen bieten auch die AKP Wahlkampf
Teams in den unterschiedlichen Regionen
auch kostenlose Bustransfers an was ein
sehr wichtiger Faktor ist gerade für das
ältere Klientel auf solche Strukturen
kann die Oppositionspartei sie HP in
stand nicht zurückgreifen sie rufen ihre
Anhänger auf zur Wahl zu gehen auf das
die Türkei wieder zurückkehre zu mir
Rechtsstaatlichkeit wie sie sagen wir
haben die Hoffnung nicht aufgegeben und
den Glauben auch nicht verloren und wir
glauben fest daran dass kemalkulis Store
gewählt wird zum 13 Präsidenten Erdogan
oder Kilic Derulo die Wahlbeteiligung
wird in Deutschland wohl wieder recht
hoch sein noch bis übermorgen können
Türken hierzulande abstimmen
bei der Präsidentschaftswahl am Sonntag
könnte eher der Königsmacher sein der
ultra-nationalistoan weil er als
Drittplatzierte nicht mehr mitmacht hat
er heute verkündet wen seine Anhänger
unterstützen sollen Ohren ruft dazu auf
für Erdogan zu stimmen fragen wir unsere
Korrespondenten Jörg Brase in elase im
Osten der Türkei ist damit die Wahl
gelaufen
also das könnte natürlich Präsident
Erdogan helfen seinen Vorsprung aus dem
ersten Wahlgang einem zweiten Wahlgang
zu verteidigen letztlich kommt es
natürlich darauf an welcher der beiden
Kandidaten dann seine Anhängerschaft am
besten mobilisieren kann am Sonntag zum
zweiten Mal zur Wahl zu gehen aber man
muss klar sehen dass es sich hier eben
nicht um den Fähren Kampf zwischen zwei
gleichwertigen Kontrahenten handelt
sondern das Präsident Erdogan mit seiner
ganzen organisationsfinanz und auch
Medien macht seine Regierung und Partei
klar im Vorteil ist in welcher
Verfassung ist die Opposition gibt es da
noch Kraft zum mobilisieren
also wir haben in den vergangenen Tagen
mit vielen Unterstützern von Kemal Kilic
staolo gesprochen und man muss sagen
viele sind frustriert und viele sind
auch noch schockiert darüber dass trotz
dieses parteienbündnisses trotz der
positiven Umfragen ist wieder eine
Niederlage gegeben hat sie versuchen
jetzt mit dem Mut der Verzweiflung muss
man fast sagen ihre Anhänger zu
motivieren sie sagen wir wurden um den
Wahlsieg betrogen es hatte
Unregelmäßigkeiten gegeben wir müssen
jetzt beim zweiten Wahlgang viel genauer
hinschauen kommt wählt und helft uns
dabei aber ich denke das wird sehr sehr
schwer danke schön für diese
Einschätzung war das
die EU hat heute eine rekordstraße gegen
den Mutterkonzern von Facebook verhängt
1,2 Milliarden Euro soll der
us-internet-riese Meter zahlen weil er
zu wenig unternehmen um die Daten von
Europäern zu schützen ultimativ heißt es
Meter solle bis Oktober den Transfer von
Nutzerdaten in die USA stoppen Meter
kündigte umgehend Berufung gegen die
Entscheidung an
und jetzt zur Parlamentswahl gestern in
Griechenland bemerkenswert hier obwohl
die Konservativen klar gewonnen haben
müssen die griecheninnen und Griechen
bald trotzdem noch mal wählen denn die
konservative Partei verfehlte mit knapp
41 Prozent die absolute Mehrheit und der
amtierende Präsident mit sutakis
schließt eine Koalition aus nach einer
Neuwahl könnte er allein regieren weil
die stärkste Partei dann dank einer
Regelung im Wahlrecht zusätzliche
bonusssitze bekommt einverstanden mit
einer Neuwahl ist wohl auch
Oppositionsführer zipras seine linke sie
Rieser erreichte nur 20%
. jetzt nach kann zu den Filmfestspielen
es gibt nur wenige deutsche
Schauspielerinnen die als
internationaler Star gelten Sandra Hülle
gehört dazu eigentlich eine
theaterbegeisterte 1978 in Suhl geboren
vor sieben Jahren schon wurde sie für
den Film Toni Erdmann in kann gefeiert
diesmal ist sie dort gleich in zwei
Hauptrollen im Wettbewerb von der Cote
d'Azur berichtet Anna Warsberg
wir lassen wirkt ihr Gang über den roten
Teppich zwischen all den Weltstars
Sandra Hüller sie ist längst eine von
ihnen die einzige deutsche in diesem
französischen Wettbewerbsfilm und das in
caor hat 9 mies das ist doch mit Stop I
did not killing in Anatomie dünnschild
Anatomie eines Sturzes spielt Füller
eine deutsche Autorin nach dem Tod ihres
Mannes muss die sich vor Gericht
verantworten mal Französisch mal
englisch es geht um Schuld Trauer und
die Grenze zwischen Fiktion und Realität
klar intim feinfühlig
in dem Raum jeder Mensch auf der Welt
hat die Fähigkeit alles zu fühlen es
geht nur um die Frage wie man das als
Schauspielerin umwandelt zulässt und die
Möglichkeit es zu zeigen
die französische Regisseurin Justin
Trier sagt sie habe die Rolle auf Füller
zugeschnitten auf die Frage ob sie das
als Schauspielerin unter Druck gesetzt
habe antwortet Hülle ernst oder auf
englisch
am Set ausgeübt was eine wirklich gute
Art zu arbeiten ist finde ich einige
Leute könnten sich ein Beispiel daran
nehmen
[Musik]
unter welchen kritischen Drehbedingungen
viele Filme entstehen deutet Sandra
Hüller bedacht an zuletzt hatte es
Vorwürfe gegen Regisseur Til Schweiger
wegen Machtmissbrauch am Set gegeben
eine Pressekonferenz die auch das
Filmfestival hinter dem roten Teppich
beleuchtet mit einer bescheiden
gebliebenen deutschen internationalen
Schauspielerin
kaum erleben wir in Deutschland die
ersten warmen Tage da lauern auch schon
wieder Gewitter heute Nachmittag war
zunächst vor allem der Westen dran oft
ziehen die Gewitterzellen nur langsam
vorwärts deshalb kam etwa hier bei
Detmold sehr viel runter bis zu 70 Liter
in der Stunde pro Quadratmeter im
Sauerland überrasten auch große Mengen
Hagel die Menschen zu viel Niederschlag
und Schlamm für die Kanalisation mit
bösen Folgen für die Anwohner auch am
Abend rauen sich in weiten Teilen
Deutschlands Gewitter zusammen zum
Beispiel hier in Hamburg
und in Dortmund brodelts unabhängig vom
Wetter da hat der BVB im Kampf um die
Fußballmeisterschaft jetzt die Nase voll
Bayern Niederlage gegen Leipzig am
Samstag folgte gestern der BVB Sieg in
Augsburg macht zwei Punkte Vorsprung
Entscheidung Sonnabend am letzten
Spieltag der BVB surft auf einer
Euphorie und Sympathie Welle in Richtung
Titel gewinnen auch dank seines
Mittelstürmers wird er zum Meistermacher
beim BVB Sebastian Alea in Augsburg
mühlt sich der BVB bis Alea einen Fehler
der Gastgeber entschlossen nutzt vieles
ist Kopfsache und das gilt nicht nur für
ein Fußballspiel der Mensch Sebastian
mit mit diesem mit diesem Willen mit
dieser positiven Energie der hat uns so
gefehlt in der Kabine auf dem
Trainingsplatz und es bleibt einfach das
größte Wunder dass Sepp diese Saison so
zurückkommen konnte nach seiner
Krebserkrankung kehrt alle er im Januar
zurück im Februar sein erstes Tor das
2:0 gestern seinen neuntes bundesliga
Tor jedes einzelne ein Schritt zum nahen
Titel Julian Brand trifft noch zum 3:0
die vorletzte Meisterprüfung bestanden
die letzte folgt
die juristische Aufarbeitung der Affäre
rund um die Fußball-WM 2006 in
Deutschland geht weiter das
Oberlandesgericht Frankfurt hat das im
letzten Jahr eingestellte Verfahren
gegen die früheren DFB-Funktionäre
Schmidt 20er und Niersbach wieder in
Gang gesetzt es geht um den Verdacht der
Steuerhinterziehung
zur Eishockey-WM in Finnland und
Lettland da steht das DEB-Team vor dem
Einzug ins Viertelfinale das
entscheidende und letzte Vorrundenspiel
morgen gegen Frankreich Deutschland ist
klarer Favorit
auch beim Fußball Tennis zeigen die
Spieler beachtliche Fähigkeiten im
Eishockey ist Deutschland längst vom
Außenseiter zu einem ernsthaften
Medaillenkandidaten gereift das zeigt
auch der klare Erfolg gegen Ungarn eine
siegreiche Bilanz in der Gruppenphase
haben mit vier Siegen und drei
Niederlagen also positiv aus der
Gruppenphase raustreten bislang läuft
die WM wir erwartet nach drei
Niederlagen gegen die großen 30-Jährige
gegen die kleineren gegen Frankreich
muss die Mannschaft von Trainer Herbert
Kreis wieder mit der Favoritenrolle
klarkommen
nicht abmelden für das Spiel die werden
morgen hat rauskommen für nichts ist
sich der Trainer zu schade wenn es nur
dem Erfolg dient
gute Einstellung das war es von Spaß
vielen Dank es wird weiter ziemlich
flächendeckend vor heftigen Gewittern
mit Starkregen gewarnt praktisch vom
Norden bis zu den alten wie das in der
Nacht und morgen weitergeht erzählt
gleich Katja horneffer Marietta Slomka
begrüßt sie um Viertel im heute-journal
wir sagen danke und tschüss und wünschen
Ihnen noch einen schönen Abend bis
morgen wenn Sie mögen
[Musik]
guten Abend die neue Woche startete mit
Gewittern die höchsten Wolken haben wir
für sie rot eingefärbt darunter
verbergen sich oft Gewitter wie hier
über der Nordsee etwa ab 14 Uhr
entwickelt sich dann auch Gewitter über
den Mittelgebirgen die hier im Sauerland
aber auch im Odenwald in der Eifel im
Schwarzwald und über der Schwäbischen
Alb nicht jeder bekam Gewitter ab aber
einige Gewitterzellen besonders die hier
im Sauerland die hatte es wirklich in
sich bis zu 50 Liter Regen pro
Quadratmeter in kaum einer Stunde sind
da runtergekommen die Gewitter
beschäftigen uns auch noch in der Nacht
sie ziehen langsam weiter ostwärts
lassen dabei aber mehr und mehr nach
Unwetter erwarten wir in der Nacht noch
hier zwischen Hamburg Hannover und
Magdeburg das wird eine milde Nacht mit
Tiefsttemperaturen zwischen 15 und 9
Grad und morgen ziehen die Gewitter dann
ostwärts ab am längsten gewittert wohl
noch hier rund um Berlin auch im
südlichen Brandenburg und im
Alpenvorland im Westen wird das morgen
schon ein ganz freundlicher Tag sondern
Wolken wechseln sich ab da sind nur
wenige Regenschauer unterwegs der Wind
kommt aus nördlichen Richtung und so
wird schon deutlich kühler im Westen
liegen die Werte bei 14 bis 18 im Süden
und Osten bei 18 bis 22 Grad und mit
deutlich mehr Sonne geht es in den
nächsten Tagen weiter guten Abend